Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the Monday
morning podcast from Monday,
November 19th, 2012. Uh,
what's going on?
How I am my,
in my apartment in New York
City and I think I am as well.
Mike as I've ever been. I bought
some new device. The one that I, uh,
actually Ari Shaffir showed me when I
did his skeptic tank podcast and um,
I don't know how to shut off the external
microphone. So I'm using a microphone.
Like I'm fucking Michael Douglas.
I got on my headphones,
I got two more stereo. Like if you
can't fucking hear me this week,
if somebody says, Ooh, pool kiss was
too quiet. All right, maybe you need to
go get miracle ear.
Do they still sell that miracle ear?
Ketia like fucking grow an ear outside
of the body at this point yet they like
grow one in a petri dish. There's not
what they're working on right now.
I mean, if they can grow the outside at
this point. Yeah, that was years ago,
years ago. They showed that on like the
local news right after some old lady.
You know who's made jam for the
last 70 years just fucking died.
Or they usually do that in the end.
No, they wouldn't. No, she died.
They do it earlier,
but if she was still alive,
just be like a jab for 70
years while she's still going.
Wow. Mike. I bet that was some wonderful
jam. The offset was we'll fuck later.
Um,
anyways, um, if this is too
loud, if this is fucked up,
it's just going to be this one week.
I just got to go find some tech person.
I'm probably tomorrow morning. By the
time you're listening to this, um,
I'm going to be doing the
opie and Anthony Show, uh, uh,
tomorrow morning and I'm going
to talk to dog. Oh, Danny boy,
the lights are calling or
whatever. I'm going to, no,
I really should know the words to that,
you know,
does anybody know the fucking
words to that? You know,
doesn't everybody just
know, oh, Danny boy. Whoa.
Right. That's like knowing the second
verse to like, God bless America. No,
not that one. It's one of those songs, one
of those songs. Everybody's just saying,
sings the first,
first one of those patriotic songs,
and then you never hear the second
verse. So now we're, and we're,
it looks at the lyrics to the second verse
and then when they finally look at it,
that's the most sexist,
racist shit ever. You know,
and then they do something about
it on TV. Should we get, uh,
the racial slur out of the second verse
or is it part of the American fabric?
You know, and then everybody on CNBC
and Msl the liberal sit there. Go ahead.
Definitely have to get rid of it.
We should trash white people in the first,
first to make up for what, seven second
verse. And then everybody on Fox News just
goes, you know, I don't see what
the problem is. They relate.
They say that we're doing each other.
I have a red tie on,
you know,
who watches since who still fucking
watches that shit and just thinks that any
of those people have a fucking flying,
I didn't know what the expression is to
have any idea what they're talking about.
Do you realize how much is going on in
the world and then what are you doing?
What are those guys do other than just
sit there and just wait for the fucking,
the teleprompter thing to
come on or the incoming news.
They still have that old technology with
that thing types forward and backward.
It's coming in,
you know,
incoming news over an England according
to this computer that some fucking
person wrote into 6,000 fucking
miles away. Evidently this happened.
I don't believe any of it.
I mean I believe it.
I believe a lot more of
it now that I travel.
That's one of the greatest
things about traveling.
When you actually see big band,
you're like, wow, it really exists.
This wasn't just meet up.
You don't have to like that paranoid
thought that maybe your town or maybe like
just state,
depending on how much you've traveled,
like that's all there is and
then you'd be just kept going.
You would actually run into that,
like that fucking atmosphere
that you can't like walk through.
Do you ever have thoughts about that?
Well I have and I'm not going to be,
I'm not going to may be made to feel
that I'm less than you cause you didn't.
Okay. Before you start judging
me during this holiday week,
what are you guys doing for the holidays?
You haven't some Turkey,
some fucking beef Jerky,
white people with the mashed potatoes,
black plague people with the
fucking sweet potatoes, right?
Jewish people. Do you guys sit
with you? Don't sit this one out.
You guys set out Christmas. You
guys have Chinese food, right?
So at least we could do
give you that one holiday.
Jewish people hook you up in September.
You barely even have to work in that
fucking month. Thanks to those people. Um,
I should have given them a shout out.
Shout a late shout out to
Jewish people in September.
Thank you for those two or three Mondays.
I always forget if it's two, three.
I know it's one that the month, right?
Labor, Labor, Labor Day. I miss this day,
flag day and then there's a Horatio
Sanz Day. What the fuck is it called?
Yom Kippor Yom Kippur.
I don't know what it is,
but thank you for all those Mondays
I've had off or is it a Tuesday?
I don't know. I don't, what the fuck is,
I don't know what it is, but this might,
at least my world. My business
shuts the fuck down on those days.
And I've never said thanks.
So during the week of
thanksgiving, thank God, um,
I kept getting, giving thanks to
Jewish people in those two, three,
one seven Mondays that I have off.
And uh, you know, there's only fork.
Go Fuck Yourself. I'm in
September. All right. So anyways,
I worked at the germline and
center for the performing
on Saturday night and uh,
had a great time.
Paul Versey went up and fucking
leveled the place. It fucking asshole.
I'm going to lose another opener.
Already lost Joe to Rosa. You know,
he took off to the, the richer
fields of headlining. Right?
I can't get that bachelor to open for me
anymore. He sees too big of a superstar.
But you know, I caught him in
the dip, the teenagers sensation,
I call him between his, his, um,
his initial success when he was a,
and I think he first broke on dance fever.
I can't remember what.
And then when disco was out,
he had a rough time and a lot
of people don't know this, uh,
to Rosa was actually offered
John Travolta's part in
pulp fiction and he turned
it down cause uh, you know, he
was still, um, what are we saying?
The business Joe was suffering
from exhaustion during
that period and he had to
go away.
So whatever.
Now he's back to headline and add a,
so now first he's opening for me.
So I'm like, all right, you know,
I can get some miles out of this kid.
This fucking assholes killing so hard.
They're not doing just the
regular clapping in the end of it,
they will like whistling the links to
the next level of, of, of, of killing.
If someone takes the effort to
just not sit there and you know,
clapping that fucking hammer,
they got to actually bring their
dirty fingers to their mouth.
They probably went to the bathroom.
They don't give a shit about the bacteria.
Right.
Okay.
And they actually, what's so for
you, when I hear that I, I got,
I got maybe another eight months.
So if you want to see the legendary
tandem of Paul Versey and myself on the
road, you better come soon because it's
fucking assholes killing. So anyways,
we were at, at uh, what does it
southern Connecticut University.
Did I say it right? I don't know why. Um,
it was open to the public.
So it was a college Gig,
but it wasn't really a college kid.
We were actually at the John Lennon and
center for the performing arts that was
on that campus. And it
was mainly, you know, uh,
people who had already graduated college,
uh,
which made me feel comfortable
actually means for us.
We were both nervous cause you know,
he's 10 years younger than I am and I'm
actually sitting there going like, okay.
And then incoming freshmen
was born in 1994. Fuck me,
I was already doing comedy two years,
two fucking years.
What am I going to talk to this
person about? You know what, what,
what I, I haven't done a college
gig in years. I don't know.
People say you should do
them to keep you at your,
yeah. I was actually talking to
someone about this the other day,
like how you stay relevant as
a performer. As you, you can't,
once you start selling tickets
and you have a fan base,
you can't just do those shows.
You have to keep going down to the comedy
club where it's a 100 people who just
showed up that night and could give a
flying fuck who you are and whether you're
funny or not,
and then you can stay current,
but if you just get your crowd and you
just keep performing to them as you get
older,
they get older and then one day they
start fucking dying or something and then
that's it.
You're standing out there and this old
fucking guy in a wrinkled brown suit.
It's terrible. There's fucking
business that the back nine is brutal.
The back now, he was brutal. That's
why I'm fucking, I got to do something.
Yeah.
I got to get my two pistols and learn
how to hunt and freeze and elk. Okay.
Come see my act. I'll explain
the rest of that. But anyways,
what was really interesting was this,
um,
the John and center for the
performing arts was, um,
a stone's throw from Yale University.
No, I've never been
there. I've been to have,
I've done a show at Princeton Dat myth
and I've walked by the one here that's in
New York.
I forget what it's called,
on the way to some lady's apartment back
in the day when I was a stud back in
the day,
way back in the late nineties,
when all Billy red face first
came to the fucking city,
right. Look, and like Richie Cunningham,
how I ever got laid
back then was just fine.
I had to get on a stage and
fucking jumped around. I had to,
what else was I going to do? Sit there
and looking like a fucking puppet.
Um, anyways, but I've never,
I never been to Yale. I know I drove
by, I had no idea where it was at.
Every dental he gets in new haven,
Connecticut. And, uh, believe me,
I've heard some shit about Connecticut.
You know what I mean? I definitely have,
I know there's a lot
of a blue blood money.
They're blue blood but blood
money and I know that there's a,
Oh fuck.
You don't have to just reminded me of,
I finally figured out a way to work in
the so called white man into my act.
I was walking my dog. God Damn
it. Somebody send me a tweet.
Just write the so called
white man and let me,
I'll just have to think about that
way. The fucker would go in. God Damn.
And I was going to do it last
night. Fuck. Um, anyways,
so I've heard a lot of shit about
Connecticut. That's, you know, there's a,
you know, I'll let JP Morgan money, the
blue bloods, the guys, you know who,
who like they, their kids haven't
worked for fucking generations,
haven't worked since like
their, their, their initial, uh,
since that meeting on Devil's island.
They haven't fucking work is
some Klan members higher level,
no southern accents, you know, pushing
the ponds around. I've heard about that.
I've heard that there's a mix
of patriots and giants fans.
And then I heard that there was,
uh, some rough areas of high Flynn.
I definitely heard that,
but I never heard about new haven,
so I dunno,
I figured it's,
it's an ivy league campus.
I figure it's got to be cool to walk
around or whatever. So anyways, I'm like,
you know what,
I know that the Yale bulldogs play
in an old stadium just like, yeah,
I want to go look at it.
So I looked it up on Wikipedia and
said the Yale Bowl they're claiming is
actually the original bowl in this country
and that all the other bowls looked
at that ball and said, wow,
we want to build one to one.
That's how you got the Rose Bowl,
the fucking cotton bowl and all
those other bolts. And that's,
and then from that they took the name
bowl for the bowl games cause they all
played in those fucking stadiums.
And then from there the Superbowl
took the bull name from that.
So it all goes back to this. So I'm like,
well, fuck me, I got to go see this thing.
So I look on my map.
Okay,
my little Google maps.
I see it's a mile and a half away.
I hate going to the fucking gym, right?
I had my banana and apple for breakfast.
I'll go fucking full of fiber.
I'll go take a walk down to the Yale Bowl,
go check this motherfuck around.
It's a mile and a half away.
I'm in an Ivy League, I'm on an Ivy League
campus. This, this, how can I go wrong?
Right.
I got about two blocks in.
This is an amazing thing where
you suddenly as a white person,
realize that you're walking into the hood.
There's those subtle signs,
you know that make you nervous.
First thing you see is a probably a check
cashing place. You know what I mean?
A funeral home, Baptist church,
you know, less white people.
You start going fuck. And I'm thinking,
well, it's only a mile and a half away.
How bad can it fucking get
plus this during the day?
Okay,
do I never had a problem during the
day? During the day? The regular people.
It's at night right around seven o'clock.
I've always said when that second
shift comes out, the hustlers,
the zombies and all that fucking shit,
that's what you don't want to be there.
But uh, you know, you might catch a
couple of those guys coming home late,
you know what I mean?
So I'm fucking walking through their Ed a,
I've got to admit, I got about
six blocks in and I was waiting.
I felt like I was in
an episode of the wire.
Like I was waiting for Omar a hill to
come walking by with his fucking gun.
It was crazy.
I also figured out why
black people walk so slow
when they were walking down the street.
I get it because when you walk slow,
you look like you're not nervous. Okay.
If you're walking fast like I was,
you look like either a,
a narc or a fucking victim.
He love, he, he's scared.
Okay.
People just was staring. I don't know,
just my fucking red face. I think I'm,
I really freaked out a lot of
people cause there was nothing,
nobody down there that looked like me.
So I finally got through all this fucking
shit and I get down to the Yale bowl
cause I want to look at this thing they
get is going to look like the one at
[inaudible]. Right. That's
basically a rip off of uh,
what does that place over there in Italy?
Yeah.
The place where they threw
all the Christians to the
lions and that fat guy who
was balding and he'd do the thumbs up,
thumbs down,
wasn't punches pilot. He took out the
Hippie Julius Caesar. Who the fuck was it?
The Roman Colosseum. So I thought
it was going to look like that.
So I show up to this thing.
It's dug into the fucking ground.
All I can see as these entrances and
that have gates in front of him and above
them is just grasp.
I couldn't see a fucking thing.
So then I had to turn around and I had
to walk right back from the hood and I
was way less nervous the
second time because I knew
with each step I was getting
closer to my hotel.
It's weird how that works.
Then I started looking around and people
looked a lot more friendlier cause that
was a lot less nervous. And you know
what? I think that's one to grow on.
And you know what's funny is I
actually want to go to war, uh,
Harvard Yale game in a,
at the Yale Bowl.
I want to do that because I started
thinking about how many future presidents
sat in the Yale bowl or at least
candidates. You know what I mean?
George W.
Bush was in there as was that other
fucking guy that ran against him in 2004
John Kerry. You know what I mean? They
might've done keg stands together.
So I just want to look at drunk
kids out there and be like,
maybe someday that's going to be my guy
who was allegedly my leader, you know?
Then maybe then the Harvard Yale game,
when they're not giving each other shit
and throwing their hankies at each other.
I can actually hear you know, about
the next, the Illuminati meeting.
Hey,
you know,
I'm always bitching about the population
problem and how they never fucking
bring it up in the presidential campaigns.
You know what?
I think they bring it up.
I think they bring it up on that.
That Bilderberg group gets together.
I think they talk about the real problems,
you know, when they all get together
and be like, hi, what is the most,
what is the easiest way to get
7 billion down to 500 million?
You know what I mean? Is I sit there
like fucking lobsters and shit.
Then who fucking serves him?
I bet that, I bet when you,
when you're a waiter for them, when
you come walking into that, that group,
when you bring in whatever their
fucking escargo and all that shit,
I bet they all just shut the fuck up the
second you come in or they pulled down
some different map
and if you accidentally see something
like that you're never heard from again.
Okay.
Am I slowly losing my mind? I
don't fucking know. Anyways,
this is the Monday morning podcast
everybody. And uh, as you know,
as I stated numerous times, um,
I've started a podcast network.
We're just a mom and pop store
at this point. Like I said,
eventually we're going to be blogging,
putting up video,
but it's called all things, comedy.com.
And uh, it's sort of a co op like what?
I live here in New York,
uh,
live in here in New York and um,
okay.
You know, we kind of, it's, you know,
by Adis for artists. So we're trying to,
we're trying to do,
uh,
you know what's funny about this whole
all things comedy is I was just going to
say like,
we're going to try and have like this
whole hippie commune thing and I just saw
this whole thing on Jones town,
so hopefully we don't all like
fucking drink the Koolaid,
but, um, anyways, we've
got it to new podcasts. Um,
we're adding the naughty room
and the, uh, the bone zone,
um, which are absolutely fucking, yeah,
hilarious podcasts and we'll probably
take away listenership from mine,
but I'm okay with that. You know
what I mean? Fuck, I'm actually,
Brendan Walsh is one of my favorite.
Uh,
can I even say up and coming
will probably, cause you
guys don't know who he is,
but he's been around for awhile.
I shot a failed pilot pilot
with him a long time ago.
We improv'd so this whole,
uh,
this whole scene to get and just had
a great time, you know what I mean?
Just to fucking,
there's nothing better than when you're
with somebody who knows their fucking
funny cause then they don't jump all of
your shit and then you can relax and he
can actually play off each other.
It's when you fucking get into scene and
there's some content that just tries to
fucking box you out.
Me, me, me, me, me, me, me. And
you start treating it like a lamp.
That's when it's not
fun. All right. Anyways,
so let's get on with this. What the fuck
am I going to talk about this week? How,
how far into this thing am I,
what am I, what am I, what am I,
18 minutes in my fucking
hot ass God damn apartment.
I told you guys a long time ago when my
apartment is so hot and it's not cause
I'm in it. Hey, uh,
it's because somebody in this building,
either their kid got sick or they got
sick. I don't know if there's still sick,
but evidently,
unless it's fucking 90 degrees in here,
they're going to get sick again.
So everybody in the building has stuff
fucking suffer instead of these fucking
dickheads just buying
a God damn space here.
They just cranked it.
I saw what is dragging up my floors.
I swear to God. I could see I could
catch fucking malaria in my apartment.
Just disgusting.
So anyways,
the fuck was I going to talk about,
did you guys watch any football this week?
Did you watch you watch the
Patriots scored 59 fucking
points against the colts,
but I got to tell you something. How
great does Andrew Luck Look? You know,
I knew we throw, I know we throw a
couple of pics sixes, but whatever.
He's a rookie that's going to happen.
And he didn't have this,
this freaked out look on his face.
He threw a pick six things like fuck, you
know, like that guys is going to be a,
I'm not saying anything you
don't already know. And uh,
Kudos to the Indianapolis Colts.
Huh?
Did they play that at the end of Peyton
manning? They played that out perfectly.
You know, they probably knew we
had another two, three years.
But what are the odds you're going to,
you're going to go from Peyton manning
to a guy. He's good. As Andrew Luck.
Do you realize how, what a,
what a smart move that was.
That's like in those cartoons
when someone's fallen down
the cliff and the phone
booth and right before it crashes, they
step out. That's basically what they did,
you know, in the short run. Yeah, they
fucked themselves, I guess. You know,
Peyton starting to click with the Broncos.
I like the Broncos to possibly go to the
Superbowl going out on a fucking Lynn.
There is every other team is
injured. Um, not really. I'm,
I'm joking about going out on a limb, but
um, you know, I know it was, what was it,
59 to 24 gives a fuck that kid that
kid could throw in that kick in play.
And, uh, I really hope the Patriots,
I can't even get myself to say this
cause it's my quarterback so I won't even
say it out loud,
but at some point the person with
that cute little dimple in his chin,
it's not going to be quarterback
anymore for the Patriots.
And I hope we're lucky enough
to go from that jewel guys.
Good as Andrew Luck. That is the shit
that's, it's very rare that that happens.
I would probably say the greatest one
that I ever saw was the 40 niners going
from Joe Montana to Steve
Young. Other than that, uh,
not even the dolphins,
they went from Bob Greasy to like dawn
struck before Dan Marino came in and then
Dan Marino, his career ended and
then they haven't had anybody,
Joey Harrington from the
lions will fuck have they had,
okay.
Chad Pennington from the jets.
I always thought that that guy could
play and just could never stay healthy.
I mean the fucking jets went
from Joe Nemeth to nobody.
This still waiting for
the next Joe Nemeth.
That's how amazing it is and how
much you fucking freak out when you,
when you get the real deal.
I guess the Patriots went from drew
Bledsoe to Tom Brady, you know,
and I know Bledsoe gets a lot of shit,
but I mean that guy was a,
he was up there, right?
He's got the fucking yeah,
to prove it.
No,
it's fights fucking unreal because the
cowboys cowboys went Roger Stolle back
then they had that long low. Then Troy
Aikman came in and now they're in another,
they're in like a fucking 20 year.
Well now wait, how long did it trade?
Mentally he played the like a 2000 maybe.
And there's still waiting.
Although Tony Romo was not as bad.
He's not as bad as people say. Bill,
you're going to make any
of this fucking funny.
You just going to sit here and talk about
how you remember quarterbacks I write.
I write already. Um, could you hear that?
Could you fucking hit up Jesus Christ,
another person telling me they
lost the house in a storm.
Holy fucking shit. All right. There's
another thing to give. Thanks for that.
That didn't happen to me. God dammit. Um,
okay.
You know what the great thing about being
a comedian is all you can actually do
a bunch of benefits and,
uh,
I've actually gotten some offers out
on the west coast to do some, I gotta,
I gotta jump on one of those.
I got to jump on one of those.
But the funding or what the
fuck's going on? You don't,
you realize I don't even watch the news
anymore. I'm just so fed up with it.
I don't know if I'm fed up with it
or I'm so out of my fucking mind.
They can't even relate to it anymore.
I just sit there,
y'all on TV and that's fucking Paul
shared. You know, I don't fucking know.
You know, let, let's get, let's get to
a, God damn. I'm just get to a fucking,
oh, how about a big shout out to
the, they're actually thinking
about taking a couple of weeks off.
It just can't come to a fucking agreement.
So they're going to take a couple of weeks
off. You know what I'm going to do? I,
I've, I'm, I'm done with them. I'm
fucking done with them. You know,
every sports fan says that and then they
get all excited when they come back to
fuck them. I'm bi, I'm
getting the NBA League pass.
I've actually been watching the Celtics
for the first time in forever were
actually younger and a,
I liked the way we're playing.
I liked the way we're playing and I
like every fucking team in the league,
including the neck. Just as long
as they beat the Lakers. That's it.
I'm old school. I don't give a shit.
I don't give a fuck about the heat.
There's still an expansion team to me.
Oh good for you.
With your two little banners,
you know,
I hope you get some more banners when
the air conditioner is turned on and it
starts waving. It dries out all the
fucking botox around court side.
How about that?
How do you like that?
That's fucking creepy ass town that
Miami is, I'll tell you for as much shit.
It's Hollywood gets for the
old guy with the trophy wife.
You've never seen it until you go
down to Miami beach and you see these
motherfuckers 60 fucking 65 years old,
58 maybe at the youngest with their
linen on linen matching outfit and those
Brown fucking loafers,
no sandals that look like that face mask
or that guy in the giants whose just
sick of having people
poke them in the face.
So he basically has a durable cage on
his face though. Those kinds of sandals,
those rich guys sandals probably
made an Evana kind of sandals.
Those guys,
65 fucking years old balls hanging down
the side of their linen pants inside
leg. Of course it's not
get disgusting, right? And,
and they're sitting there with
like some fucking 19 year old.
Okay.
Was unreal. Just fucking
unreal. It's just disgusting,
disgusting thing that's going
on down there. You know what?
They got enough money to cover it up.
How was that legal?
Once you're of legal age that you can
be 58 with a fucking 19 year old climate
on a fucking 19 year old,
right?
She's into all this new music.
You don't know.
You're sitting there putting
on fucking a Glenn Miller
Moonlight serenade, anything.
What the fuck it is? It's,
they feel like they're in the little
rascals movie. Extras, disgusting
and awesome.
All at the same time.
Just depending on what side of the ball
you're wrong. Let's be honest. So anyways,
yeah,
I'm becoming a big hoop fan.
I actually watched some of the Knicks
game today with the Paul Versey.
And what about the fucking
next seven and one?
Go listen to Paul's fucking podcast.
He's going to be freaking out about that.
Tell you the next kid. Um,
he still says kid and Yab.
Boy when he fucking text,
he's really starting to show his age,
but only in this texting. All
right, here we go. Some, uh,
some questions for the week. Hey Bill,
how do I tell my wife I'm an atheist bill.
I have the greatest wife in the world
and we have two wonderful daughters.
This is starting off like a horror movie.
You know what I mean?
How it's always like nice. There's
always like leaves falling in a Gazebo,
but there's just that
hint of creepy music.
I at least to do that back in the 80s,
when they couldn't just
depend on special effects,
they actually had to build suspense.
That's how this is looking at this guy.
He has a great, here's a great, he has
the greatest wife in the world. Everybody,
and he has two wonderful daughters.
Uh, there's a problem though,
Don Don, uh, she is a devout Christian.
All right, do you, why are you
acting like you just met her,
you fucking married her.
And he goes and I finally decided
that I don't believe in any of it. Oh,
that's why. Oh, we'll do
welcome to enlightenment.
You know, you can't throw it all
out the window, but you know,
the seven deadly sins,
the 10 commandments,
all that shit makes sense. But all that
other stuff, you know, burning Bush,
talking to a bath, it's walking on a
fucking lake. I mean, come on. I mean,
how are we adults here or what,
you know,
you have to throw your first baby
over a cliff to show that you love me.
Hey, I was just fucking with you. You
passed to tell what the, what is that?
Okay.
Booming voice coming
from the clouds ghetto.
I just don't buy it. Something's coming
back like for the love of God. What, what,
what is it waiting for?
You know what I mean?
Is Jesus like Thurman Thomas Trying
to find his fucking helmet during the
Superbowl? Is that, what's
that? What's going on here? Um,
that's too Thurman Thomas references two
weeks in a row you find another fucking
podcast that does it. Three
weeks in a row of God. It,
you should stop listening to
this one. Um, anyways, he says,
I finally decided that I
don't believe in any of it.
I thought about telling her the old joke.
We're both atheists.
I just believe in one less God.
Then you do a,
but she wouldn't find that funny
at all. She is okay. She, she's,
she is okay for now going to church
without me because I work nights,
but I have a feeling that when the kids
get a little older that I will have to
become more involved.
Should I tell her now or just let it
be and hope that it never comes up.
Well, I have to tell you, sir,
if you do in fact have the
greatest wife in the world,
she'll accept you for who you are.
And if you're an atheist and you don't
believe in the stuff that she believes
in,
yeah,
then you know, there you go.
This is what I would do. Let her,
let her take him to church.
I Dunno what to do.
You don't be funny. What if
you took up needlepoint? Okay.
And when you went to church,
you just did needle point with your
legs crossed in the most feminine way
possible.
Maybe that's the way you do it.
Like some passive aggressive
way that you so embarrassed,
the most wonderful way from the
world that she asked you not to come.
You know
what?
If you do like a needle point that just
is like little atheistic sayings and you
make pillows and when they
have like the church drive,
like the bake sale and they wash your car,
you sell,
you sell the pillows that you, so
during the mass, Oh, you know what?
And they say Jesus is Lord.
But it's almost like,
like one of those pink Floyd
songs that if you, if you play it,
I don't know if you listened to some,
they got like hidden messages or
something or maybe they never did.
Maybe just these Jesus freaks did,
that's going to really freak them out.
Okay.
It may have like subtle messages and like
the outskirts of the pillow about this
is all a bunch of bullshit
and uh, you don't believe in
pedophilia, you know? Oh Jesus,
I'll get me some fucking emails.
Okay. Um, anyways, what are the asks?
Should I tell her now or just let it
be and hope that it never comes up? Um,
you're basically saying,
should I,
should I man up and be who I am or
should I stick my head in the sand?
Okay. That's that. Those
are your two options.
So I am going to throw this back at you,
sir. What kind of man do you want to be?
Do you want to be the kind of man that
sticks his head in the fucking sand when
there's,
there's a confrontation or do you want
to be that guy who just sits down and
just says, listen sweetheart,
I tried. I just don't,
I don't believe it.
Okay.
And I think it's great
that you believe it.
If you want to go down there and
sing the songs, shake some hands,
close your eyes, right? Make a pledge for
Jesus. Whatever the hell you want to do.
You go down there and you do that. All
right? It's like watching football.
I like doing it. You don't, you don't,
you're not into it. You know I don't,
I don't make you watch football, do
I? I don't do that. You know why?
Cause I'm the greatest husband in
the world. Why don't you try that?
Just ask her. Listen, wait.
Does she know,
okay.
She all right.
She knows that you're not going,
ah, Jesus. You know what,
you might want to give her a little Jesus
juice and uh, get a little liquored up.
I don't, I don't want to, you know, what
do you got? You got to tell her you don't,
I don't like how you're
deliberately working.
I feel like you've deliberately working
late on Sundays or early on Sundays.
Whenever the hell she goes. So
you, so you can just avoid this.
You're avoiding ships are, and
this is a snowball. All right?
A snowball, a Jesus and it's
rolling right down towards you.
And at some point it's good. It's
going to grow all over you. You know?
And there's going to be some fucking creep
church like that priest on the fucking
soprano's that's going to come over and
fucking hold your hand when
you're out there doing the, yeah,
you're a little job there. All right.
So I say, you just tell them, just say,
I just look, just be, don't be a
Douche. Just say I totally respect.
I mean I'm fucking around cause
they don't make this shift funny.
I don't care if you believe in that shit.
God bless you. You know, you know what,
I hope you're right so you can
laugh at me. Um, and we all die.
Um,
and so it really,
I'm going to hell for the rest of
my fucked for the rest of my life.
You don't think that's a little overkill?
I think the Rockefeller laws
of fucking bad anyways. Um,
yeah, just say, look, I respect that you
were under that type of stuff and listen,
you know what I do? Who gives a
fuck? Somebody took you to church.
Somebody took you to church and you
after a while realize that you didn't
believe in it. So if she wants
to take the kids to church,
just let her take him to church.
But your wife has to be okay with the
fact that they, they say gay have them.
You don't go down and pray.
Do they hippie? You can say,
cause I don't believe in that stuff.
I don't think it happened. Okay.
And a couple of years you'll understand
what I mean when I tell you about all
saint nick, when they tell you the
real story, you know, there you go.
Santa Claus for adults every Sunday.
All right, Bill, do I go for it?
A belly fat face? Uh, love
the podcast, but be boo,
I need your opinion on something.
So like a typical douchebag.
I always joke with my wife
about having butts, sex.
He goes, just because it
makes you uncomfortable. Dude.
Blood sex is one of the funniest
fucking words ever because it's,
it's, it's uh, but sex, it's
it, it's really fucking,
it almost, you know, it's almost
a sound effect of you pulling out,
but sex, you know, or going
in. That's disgusting.
I'm so much more disgusting on this
thing that I am in my regular pocket.
I'm in my regular act,
but a yeah, buts, but sex,
it's really like blunt
force kind of trauma there.
Can you hear every time I shift on the
couch so fucking well, Mike Tier, um,
he goes anyways.
The other day she offered to try it.
If I quit saying fuck and using the
Lord's name in vain for a month.
Honestly,
I never thought about trying it except
in high school with the chick using the
anal virgin loophole.
Should I go for it? Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself. Um, no,
no you shouldn't.
Okay.
And not because I'm some purist and I'm
saying you shouldn't bang your wife in
the ass. Okay. That's your legal property.
You can do with it what you want.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm just fucking with you.
No you shouldn't.
You know why you shouldn't cause you
have to do some sort of fucking parlor
trick. Hey, if you jump through
these fucking three hoops, you know,
then you can have a cookie.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Okay?
Go Fuck Yourself. See, it's too late
to say that. You know, if, if you to,
if you don't put your shoes on the rug,
maybe you can put the pepper. Yeah.
You know what?
Maybe if you paid for the NFL package,
I'll let you ride me about that.
Why do they always act like what they
have is so much better than what the fuck
you have.
You know why?
Cause we're weaker when like the fat guy
who can't resist a cookie and they're
sitting over there written
fucking salad laughing at us.
You know what you need to do, sir?
You need to get in control your Dick,
you gotta get your fucking Dick and check,
okay?
This is the one thing for
you and for everybody else.
Lists every other guy listening to this.
Don't ever do a fucking party
trick for a sexual favor.
Go Fuck Yourself. All right? I'm not a God
damn chimp. That's what he got through.
Just rub one out. Rub One out, and
then you're not going to give a shit.
You don't what she should've said if she
said it, if the second she said she'll,
she'll offer to try it.
See right there.
All that means is you're not going to
say fuck for a month and you're not going
to say, God Damn Jesus Christ. It's
God Damn fucking Dean, Jesus Christ.
It doesn't work. You're not be
able to say that for a month,
just so you can sit there and for
fucking eight eighth of a second,
because she goes,
Whoa,
and then that's it. And then
you're going to go g Christ, right?
And then she's going to
sit there and be like, oh,
see you just going to go back
to saying that. You know,
I thought it was really nice that you
didn't say that to like a whole math,
right, and now you're fucking in that.
You know what it is. It's like you gave,
you gave up, you gave up
that real estate. Okay.
Just like the native Americans, just
like the Mexicans. When you lost Texas,
you know what you have to do.
You know what Mexicans have to do
to get that fucking thing back.
Do you realize the level of bloodshed
that they have to fucking did to ever get
that back? Okay. This is the
same thing in the fucking,
this is the Louisiana purchase right here.
You never get it back.
If you fucking sit there and act like
a goddamn point extra for a month and
don't talk like how you normally talk,
just so you can just basically a knock
on the door of her butthole to have.
Right.
I love how you have to do the
entire thing that she wants.
Just so she can attempt
to maybe do what you want.
See what's you see what happened?
All right,
now you get a pass on this one, cause
this is your first time at the Rodeo.
So you missed it this time, but the
next time she does some shit like that,
I'll use this one as an example.
I'll let you do that if you know,
if you just try and do not say fuck and
use the Lord's name in vain for a month,
you don't. You should have said, you
should have said, sweetheart, I love you,
but fuck that. Okay. And get
out of the way that God, MTV
and in a weird way, she'd
respect your more cheap,
respect you more. You know what, dude?
You ought to be able to finish your way
into that. Fucking move into that, that,
that, that act at this point. All right?
You gotta be able to
talk your way into it.
You ought to be able to make her want
to do it at this point. All right.
Stop looking for the fucking
pass interference call.
Sit and get the first down.
Why don't you fucking earn it?
Unlike half the fucking quarterbacks
in the league these days. All right.
Okay. Sorry. That was tough
love. But you needed it.
Did she did everything but make
you put a fucking red nose on, um,
pink boxing gloves.
Jesus Christ felt I was watching the
boxing match between Adrian Broner and
Antonio Demarco and they
both have pink gloves.
Broner is wearing pink shorts.
It's fucking November 18th.
I don't know if you were into boxing.
Well,
the way I try to pronounce their names,
you can tell them that.
You know what it is.
I love boxing, but uh,
it's on Saturday nights and I'm
always working, so I miss it.
MMM.
Jimmy Dore, the great Jimmy door. He
always orders the fights and he always,
you know,
once every 10 fights,
I'm in town and I'll try and go over
there and watch him. He's a big,
big fight fan and a phenomenal comic. One
of my favorites. All right. Um, he says,
I don't know if you're into boxing,
but I know that if you watch this match,
you would have been furious.
I'm not, I, you know, I don't
give a shit. I just, it's,
I just think,
you know,
you could just see the writing on
the wall with all this pinch shit.
Eventually there's going to be a real
sports segment or there's going to be a 60
minutes segment.
I'm calling it right now,
like Paul Versey that there's going to
be some big fucking thing about how much
goddamn money these
corporations made off of,
off of um,
all this pink stuff that they
made off of this horrific disease.
You know what I mean?
At five hour energy.
A portion of the proceeds. Yeah.
How, how, how much of a portion,
how much of the portion goes to fighting
breast cancer and how much goes to you
and your fucking yacht? Huh? They
had tassels on your fucking shoes.
You don't, you don't, I love about that
pink. It's just a raising awareness.
Why don't you fucking tell us
how not to get it. You know,
from what I've been reading lately is
what you want to do is you want to eat
some of the, uh, some of the power
foods there. You don't like Kale.
Lot of those leafy Greens,
Bok Choy and all that type of things.
Their fill a fucking nutrients and they
actually help repair yourselves before
they go all the way over
into a cancerous cell.
Can you believe I have the fucking balls
to talk about something? This medical?
Do you realize I'm just sitting here?
Then I got three quarters away through
that sentence before I actually realized
like, wow, I am in way over my fucking
head. I don't even own a lab coat.
I've just been reading that book, uh, um,
eat for life and I got to tell you, dude,
I actually unbelieving in this because
I've tried. I did the ABS diet.
I've done all those fucking
diets, the pie protein, low carbs.
I've done all of that shit. And every time
I was on those, I always had cravings.
Like, fuck I miss bread.
Fuck, I want ice cream. Fuck.
So what they should call those
diets, you know? But this thing here,
fill it up with Fiba.
It's been ridiculous.
It's actually easy to do.
I have a banana for breakfast.
Then I wait like an hour
and then I have an apple.
Then I'm good to lunch and I sit down
and I have a giant fucking salad and it
fills me up. I feel great. Throw
some beans on there and I'm good.
I got to tell you something. You eat
like that. You'll never be constipated.
Ever eat like a rabbit. You will shit
like a horse. Trust me. Trust me.
If you see those shows,
the one that was at that fucking lady,
you are what you eat for your meal
in, in a meal out. I was like,
what? What are you talking
about? I ate three meals a day.
You're gonna tell me I'm going
to fucking, you know, fucking,
uh, at the end of the night, I
got a six spot posting up a six.
The triple double a fucking shitting.
You're telling me that that's
going to happen. I'm telling you,
if you fucking eat like that, it's
gonna happen. It's gonna happen.
I don't know. I don't know what the fuck
I'm talking about, but uh, I, I have,
I've actually for once
I'm starting to read up on
nutrition and, uh, I don't know,
give, give that book a read. Let
me know what you think. By the way,
there's no advertising on the
podcast this week. None whatsoever.
I'll tell you why at some
point. Um, all right, Bill,
how much weight do I need to
lose to be fuckable? Oh, Jesus.
Uh, all right. Just saying that your
Europe decent looks. Here we go.
Dear Bill, a big fan of yours. Go
Fuck Yourself. That was perfect. Look,
compliment and an upper cut. I
liked it. He goes, I'm a fat ass.
I'm six one and used to weigh
400 pounds as of January,
2010 I've lost weight with little effort
on my part and now weigh 337 pounds.
Basically,
I lost weight by giving up soda,
adopting a one animal prob product,
meal philosophy,
and exercising two to three days a
week at the gym. Congratulations, dude.
That's awesome. I've got a
charge out of that. That's great.
You're attorney itself
around. Good for you. He goes,
I currently work at Satan's
asshole Walmart. Uh,
I will talk about them in another
email. Oh, do buy it by all means.
By all means. Hey Al, you people who
work with for these giant corporations,
if you're seeing some CD shit,
by all means send it to me.
I'd love to read the stories or if you're
actually doing some good shit and you
want to bring down my paranoia a little
bit, I'll read the good shit too.
All did good shit. Fucking Douche. Uh,
my with them doesn't allow me to get
much exercise and this time a year or so
increasing my exercise,
Aina possible eight possible till January.
This question is for the lovely Nia.
Well,
she's not here right now and I fucked
you guys over last week cause I didn't
have time to do, uh, uh,
Neil Ogg anyways. Uh,
he says, how much, how much weight
would I have to lose to be fuckable?
I got a John Goodman,
Patton Oswald like potato face and want
to trash pat and I didn't know you were
gonna say that. Um, sorry. Pam,
one of the best fucking comics out
there. Absolute beast. There we go.
Sorry, I don't read these till
they read them. My apologies.
Here's the link to my Facebook
picture with my skinny brother.
Let her see her.
Remember I am lazy.
I want the bare minimum to be fuckable
way. I got to go with this one now.
Here we are in faith. Jesus Christ. Dude.
All right, hang on a second. Let's look
at this here. There's your brother.
All right. To, how much weight
do you have to lose? All right.
The first thing you've got to do
is get some contacts. All right.
Lose those glasses.
I like how you're dressed.
You got a nice suit on.
I would say ya
get, you win the game. What'd you say?
Three 37 [inaudible] you know
I gotta tell you something new,
but if you get down to two 75,
you get down to two 75.
Yeah, you six one two 75
year. You football weight,
you'd be fine to 75.
You could carry that and then just
keep going and get down to like two 30.
You'd be good. I'd keep rocking
the suits. I'd lose the glasses.
Or you know what I would do if you, if
you'd like, if you don't like context,
get a, uh, get a hipper more,
uh, you know, I'm judging Europe.
You're fucking souffle kind of
glasses. You know those, those,
that they were on TV, you could turn
it around. You're right there. Dude.
You're within 50 fucking pounds.
But a,
I wouldn't use the holidays as an excuse
not to lose weight. Dude. Just, um,
you know what? Here's one for
you. Get that fucking book. Um,
uh, eat to live. Get
that book, eat to live.
Just read the first hundred pages of it.
You'll get the gist of it.
And I'm just telling you,
you start turning yourself around.
You start losing fucking weight without
even having to go to the gym. All right?
Uh, he said, remember, I am lazy. I
want the bare minimum to be fuckable.
Dude,
you know,
something you got going for you as
you've got a great sense of humor too.
You get down to two 75 all right?
And you're funny and you're a
warm guy and you wear a suit.
I'm telling you it's going to
start happening for you. All right?
And you send me the fucking email about
Walmart and when you start getting late,
I want to know what the number was.
All right? Okay. Where are we now?
How many fucking minutes on 47 minutes.
Jesus Christ and coming up short
this week. Uh, overrated, underrated,
overrated. Making the bed.
Throughout my entire life,
I've noticed I've not once voluntary,
voluntarily made the bed.
I see it as a pointless, trivial tasks
that makes it serves no other purpose,
but to please other people with OCD
by giving them a sense of completion.
Why spend even more
then a minute of my day to fix something?
I'm going to mess up in 14 hours anyway.
If I did my math correctly,
people spend an average of 81 days worth
of time making the bed in their life.
Kim Kardashians. Marriage lasted
shorter than that. What a waste of time.
If you, if you're living alone, do cause
there's tight. Be any smaller here.
If you're living alone, you're,
you're made out to believe.
Making the bed is unnecessary.
Must do thing right next to
showering and brushing your teeth.
Who am I trying to impress?
If nobody else is around,
even if people around to see it,
what does it matter?
It's not like I don't have a clean house.
Does making my bed alone really determined
my cleanliness to others? What's next?
Tying our shoes after taking them off.
That's actually a good analogy.
Perhaps organizing our trash before
throwing it away. It's just ridiculous.
You know what? I get a lot of
that. But you know something?
Coming home to a bed that's making also
make you feel good. And also who knows?
You go out to Applebees just to go out
and get yourself some Mozzarella sticks,
right? And all of a sudden
you, you'll hook up with some
shit. You bring her home.
I'm telling you, she's like, what
am I doing with this strange guy?
Is fucking apartment.
Smells may be a little weird.
I'm telling you a messed up
bed can be a deal breaker.
Girls look at a messed up bed,
they'd probably think you're fucking just
all over everything or banged another
broaden there and next thing you know
she's got a half a foot out the door,
you know. But I, I do see,
I do see what you're saying and
I don't want to make the bed,
but I gotta tell you
when I do make the bed,
when I do come at night and the bed is
made, I, it actually makes me feel good.
You know
how many times have you lost something in
the bed? Is Cell phones under a pillow,
right? You lose your shoe horn. Some other
fucking thing that nobody uses anymore.
Um, youtube, Bam of fans.
Oh, I got to see this.
I didn't even watch this
youtube video of the week.
I want to see this. Is it a bunch of
hot chicks with that? Great fucking,
this video is no longer available
due to copyright claim. Ah,
fucking crap bar to bar stool
sports was going to have that.
They're like always on the cutting edge
of all this sports stuff that you wanted.
I, you know what, I have that guy
as a guest way back in the day. Um,
so anyways,
where the fuck am I going to be coming
up 50 minutes and watch me chill somehow
kill 50 minutes. Why do I feel like I'm
required to give you an hour? You know,
wait a minute. You're working as short
week. You're only working til Wednesday.
Why don't I got to put in a full
fucking hour, you know, you know why?
Cause I'm a solid fucking guy.
I'm not a solid guy and just
have a fucking need to be
liked. That's what it is.
I'm going to be at the, um, at the, uh,
the Improv in Bray California.
You see if I can get to
my fucking website, this,
what the hell am I get to my
fucking website here. Shows,
shows for the week here.
I'm going to be my last Gig of the year.
My last official one, I'm going to be
at the Improv in Bray, California. Uh,
November 30th,
December 1st and December 2nd.
And I highly recommend you go
to these shows because, uh,
I'm in a great mood
lately in my act is uh,
he's firing on all cylinders.
I got more than enough.
You know,
I was afraid because I retired the
Steve jobs bit cause I did it on
the uh,
night at too many stairs.
Did you guys watch that clip that
I send you a like a clip of that?
Um, did I send a link to
that I should say? MMM.
Can you hear me clicking here
and my stomach fucking Crowley.
I'm going to try and find this
for you right here. Cool. Anyways,
but if you get a chance to watch it,
it's night.
Too many stars just go on youtube search
that night at too many starts with the
fuck is my stomach door now.
Too many stars, uh, Bill Burn.
You'll find it on
youtube. And, uh, I never,
I got to thank Robert Smuggle cause he's,
he fought for that sec because there were
some people that were nervous cause I
was trashed and Steve Jobs and
on that network apple advertises,
which is a logical,
that's one of those corporate
decisions that doesn't bother me.
I understand that.
I'm fucking with their money.
But uh,
Robert Speigel really stuck up for me
on that one flock for this set. So, uh,
if you see it and you'll like it,
he's the reason why listen to my stomach.
If we'll do it and you hear it,
come on,
I'm to have to break it
down really quickly. Um, oh,
you know what I'm doing this week.
I'm going to my 25 year
fucking high school reunion.
I to get it down there at the time.
Did you hear her?
Gramma I'm on my 25 year
fucking high school reunion.
I haven't been to any of them
yet cause I felt like a loser.
Um,
you know what I mean?
So I'm actually gonna go back there with
a couple of my old drinking buddies and
I'm really looking forward
to seeing everybody there.
And I'm just hoping that I'm,
I'm able to have, uh, you know,
I really chose a different road,
you know,
most of the people obviously that I know,
including the guys I'm going with,
they got married, they had kids, you know,
they got the House with the picket fence,
they did that type of shit. And, uh,
so I'm just hoping that it's not going
to be like, so you're a comedian. Oh,
that's awesome.
All right.
And then everybody's just going
to talk about their kids and,
and we sitting there with my fucking
hands in my pockets, like, yeah.
So, ah, you know what? I think I
left something in my rented Geo,
you know, it's pretty confident. Move on.
I'm showing up in a fucking
rented economy car. Do you know,
I met some Douche one time,
this fucking lady and she had gone,
she had grown up in my town.
I,
she was a little bit older and,
uh,
I met her at one of my shows
and she was talking about how she had
recently gone to a high school reunion and
just was talking about how pathetic
everybody in her class was and how,
um,
she only stayed there for two hours
before she left and went back to the Ritz
Carlton in downtown Boston before boarding
her United flight back to Colorado.
I'll never forget that she used all the
names of every corporation that she was
involved in, the Ritz Carlton
in Boston, Boarding night,
United Airlines flight,
you know, and it was,
it was fucked up because as far
as I can tell from talking to her,
all she didn't life was marry a rich guy.
You know,
she's sitting there looking down on these
fucking people. It's just, you know,
United Airlines.
I liked how she said that,
like it was the fucking conquered
going to back to Paris. I don't know.
I just hope it's not,
I don't think it can be like that.
I actually came up with a
really cool grade. It was crazy.
The grade above me and the
grade below me where, uh,
they wa everybody might and my
high school were, were cool,
but they will psychos the grade
above me and the grade below me,
they just fought like they will fucking
maniacs every weekend there was some
bench clearing brawl and a party,
somebody gets a bottle smashed over the
fucking head. That was like lawsuits.
There was a dude in the grade above me.
You want to talk about party tricks?
His thing was he would eat a light bulb
and he'd be just sitting there eating it
with his gums bleeding and be smiling.
It's blood in between his
teeth like fucking maniac.
Okay, I need combat
that. It's fucking nuts.
But my grade was mellow.
We would just be like,
what was cool about my grade was
when you know, suburban shit,
everyone would end up going drinking in
the woods and everybody had their click.
And with each year the clicks
just sort of started, you know,
you know, coming together like
a virus, but in a good way.
And by the end of it, everybody was
kinda hanging out with each other.
You know,
we go up,
we used to go to this play,
this industrial park that wasn't not
developed yet and we would go down there
and there was a bunch of burned out
cars back in the day when you could just
burn cars for fucking insurance
and uh,
and nobody would do it. You know,
there was no fucking, I don't know,
it just seemed that they didn't
even investigate it. Yeah.
I got a fucking had is 74 pinto.
Yeah.
I can't believe somebody stole it
either. Had, it's unbelievable.
Then they give you money. Insurance
fraud was really easy back then and that,
and the during those days. But
anyways, we used to drink down there
and uh,
that's fine. That's all we
would do. We would just,
everyone could come down in your cars
and you see some of these headlights come
in and then everyone will be like,
is that a cop is a cop.
And there was always the people,
the experts recognizing the silhouette
of the car and like the, uh,
the square headlights
back then, it was the, uh,
the crown Vic and an 85 crown Vic
that had a very unique look to it.
And that was an aerodynamic at all and
you could just tell and everyone would
fucking scro hide the beers. All the
bullshit we were drinking. So, uh,
I dunno. So I, I haven't
gone to any of the, uh,
the union said from a
feeling like a loser.
And then I will say I kind of a paranoia
where I so liked everybody in my grade.
I didn't want to come back and
see somebody's not doing well.
I didn't want to see somebody with the
fucking gallbladder problem or somebody
divorced or just somebody you know,
want, I want to remember everybody,
the way I remembered them. Everybody
in my grade was fucking hilarious.
They had that light in there.
I know you're there at the end.
Their whole fucking lives
ahead of them. So, um,
I guess that's the thing that I'm
the most nervous about. I just want,
I want to go back and see
like happy people, you know.
Okay.
I don't want to see somebody fucked up
their back and now they can't work and
their fucking jobs fucking with them.
I'm just really hoping that
that's going to be, you know,
this is the ups and downs in life,
but I'm really hoping that that's going
to be to a fucking minimum, a minimal,
a minimum. You don't have mine nuts.
Do you guys, actually, you don't,
you guys have any high school
reunion stories? I want to hear him.
Some good ones, some nightmare ones, uh,
and that type of shit just to, you know,
keep the podcast rolling here and maybe
a different direction at some point. Um,
anyways,
that's all I got.
I could really fucking hang in here for
another fucking round and take a couple
of concussions that are going to fucking
catch up with me later on in life.
I don't want to do that.
Lead the cops on a, um,
okay.
A police chase or some fucking
thing, whatever. Oh by the way,
before we're playing the dirty
stinking jets this week, uh,
the very quiet jets, I guess somebody
was shitting all over the jets this year.
I kid shit on the jets.
They've had so many fucking injuries.
I think it's actually amazing that
they're a, the [inaudible] six and a,
what's his face?
Rex Ryan hasn't been talking shit and
there's something funny about seeing him
and uh,
that guy there raw Tony Serono with
his witness protection hat and glasses.
I know his ice got something
going on with the Zionist.
Why are you going to wear,
this is just something funny about them.
I was watching the game today before we
switched over to the next and I saw the
two of them standing there like high
fiving and hugging each other after a
touchdown. And I just started
laughing. I said, diversity. I go,
they look like two fucking guys who were
just about ready to walk into a casino.
You know,
those guys that walk into a casino still
haven't learned the lesson that they're
going to lose. They come in like rubbing
their hands like they got a system.
That's what they look like.
They looked like two guys.
They weren't like a buddy movie and you'd
fucking roof for himself. Uh, I dunno.
I Dunno. I've kind of lost my heat when
someone's not talking shit anymore.
I don't give a fuck. Is that
weird? I Dunno. Go Fuck Yourself.
So that's a podcast for
this week. Okay. Um, Nhl,
I'm sorry, I waited to damn near
December. I need another sport,
um, to offset when football's not
on. So I don't know what to tell you.
I'm getting the League pass. Um, I don't
think you should take two weeks off.
And you know what people out
there who blaming the players.
It's not the player's fault. This
is a lockout. This is the owners.
The owners are basically saying that we
don't agree with what we agreed with two
already a couple of years earlier.
That's such a fucking, like,
it's such a, it's so, so what the self,
the players really don't have an agreement
unless the agreement totally works
out for the owners. That, is that
what it is? You know what I mean?
This is what the NFL owners did last year.
Oh wait a minute,
that agreement that we agreed to,
we don't agree with anymore.
So we're taking our stadiums and going
home and unless you agree to our fucking
demands,
I dunno,
I side with the players on this
one and I really hope that they uh,
that they could work it out cause I'm,
I miss it.
I was watching this thing on Hbo.
They were running this thing on the uh,
I know this is fucked up cause I keep
leaning back and coming forward to help
this as a mess with the
recording too much. But I um,
I watched this thing on the
broad street bullies and a,
I have a love hate even
though it was before my time.
I have a love hate for that whole,
that whole fucking team just because I
always loved the fighting cause that's
what was going on when I got into
hockey. But it also, you know,
that style of play really
set the game back for a long,
long fucking time to,
to the point that people to this day
when they criticized hockey and when you
listen to them talk about it,
you would think it was the mid seventies,
early eighties. Like they don't
even fucking watch it. And uh,
I dunno.
Do you ever see that whole thing about
when the Russians came over here to play
the NHL?
He basically,
I guess it would plan for exhibition games
and everybody knew that they were the
shit. It's Canada's game and uh, you know,
the Cold War was in full effect
and it was basically like,
um, we wanted to beat
these guys. You know,
it was like saying that capitalism
was right and communism was wrong.
So the Russians came in and played
three top teams and beat all of them.
So it was down to the flyers to beat
them and the flyers, to their credit,
that coach actually
came up with the system,
which seemed like the lock of
the trap and they just fucking,
they slowed them down and the
Russians couldn't figure it out.
And once they had that goal and
they started playing flyer hockey,
which is why I really feel where
they made their fucking mistake,
they shouldn't have done that.
They should've just beat him straight up.
But basically they started throwing
elbows to the face is slash and Adam and
doing all this type of ship.
And the final one was some fucking guy
in the fly escapes out of the penalty box
and just fucking elbows.
This guy right in the face and the guy
goes down and it's not that he did it,
it was that there was no call.
So then the Russian guy calls his
players off the ice and says, all right,
fuck it. That's it. We're going home.
And I then they will show him the
flyers and the guys going, so you quit,
you take your players off the ice,
like this guy a posting.
It's like now he's not a pussy.
Okay.
It's like we fucking played you straight
up and we beat you three fucking times
in a row. We're better than
you. Even if you win tonight.
We won three out of four
and we proved that we were,
we were better during that time.
The Russian team was fucking better.
So the only way you can fucking beat
him is to basically cheat in play dirty.
I think it was fucked up,
but,
but the Russians came back out and
they ended up losing them. Uh, I dunno,
I don't want to be on American here,
but I gotta side with the Russians on
that one. I think it was fucked up.
So I imagine I'm going to hear from
a bunch of fucking angry flyer fans,
but I've never liked that shit.
I've never liked it.
I don't mind a goon fight
and the fucking goon,
but I never liked that shit in hockey
where it was just like, all right,
let's do some all Samuelson
shit. I'm not as good as you. Uh,
maybe I'll just jump on your fucking knee.
And then for some reason they then
they do that day happy a halo,
but it moves on your thing. Who
Love Them. I never got into that,
but I think it's bullshit.
But I do respect of the,
the flyers to a certain extent
and their fan base. But I,
I thought that that one was fucked up.
He should have, he had the game plan.
You can, she should have just
beat him straight up. All right.
I had to put that one to bed.
I already give you my opinion on a fucking
game that happened 37 fucking years
ago.
All right.
That's the podcast I would that I went
over an hour during the holiday week.
Sticks it everybody have a wonderful
thanksgiving. Uh, you know,
try to get along with your
relatives. Don't take the bait, okay?
You can't change the past. You
can't change them. All right?
All you can do is change the
future by, uh, by what you create.
Okay? So they, you'd go, man, that's the
most hippie thing I've ever fucking said.
And trying to be a little more positive.
All right, that's it. Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.